[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نشا القارئ عز الدين قراءه في اسره تجل
القران الكريم وتتعهده بالحفظ والتلاوه
فالتحق بالكتاتيب القرانيه وهو في الرابعه
من العمر ليتم حفظ القران في سن التاسعه
قبل انتقاله مع الاسره للعيش في هولندا
مستقرا في مدينه روتردام حيث تشكل الجاليه
المغربيه جزءا مهما من الجاليه المسلمه في
هذا البلد الاوروبي
التحق بالمدارس النظاميه الهولنديه فاتقن
لغه بلده الجديد واستمر في حفظ وتعهد
القران الكريم في بيئته الجديده الى جانب
مواصله تعليمه الاكاديمي انا
ترارات في بيئه بيئه قرانيه صراحه حيث ان
جل اعمامي يحفظون القران الكريم
وابي يعني سلك نفس المسلك ونفس الدرب وسعه
جاهدا واجتهد ليحفظ ابناءهم القران الكريم
فيعني دخلت المسجد وعمري تقريبا اربع
سنوات لم اذهب الى المدرسه العاديه وانما
ذهبت مباشره الى المسجد الى الكتاتيب
والتحقت
بالكتاتيب في القريه التي كنت يعني اسكن
فيها وعمري اربع سنوات فختمت الختمه
الاولى
وعمله تقريبا تسع تسع سنوات ولله الحمد
وفي العاشره من عمري انتقلت الى هولندا مع
الوالد والوالده
وفي هذا وفي هولندا طبعا هنا التعليم
العادي ان صح التعبير تعليم اجباري فلتحق
بالمدرسه تعلمت فيها اللغه الهولنديه
يعني
بدا التركيز يعني يقل شيئا ما
لانك طيله اليوم
يعني عندك مدرسه وعندك اعمال اخرى فكنا
نحفظ القران الكريم في يعني في اخر النهار
حينما ننتهي من المدرسه نجتمع انا وبعض
الاصدقاء في البيت
وياتينا شيخ من المشايخ اتفق معه الوالد
فكنا نحفظ القران في البيت انا لم احفظ
القران في المساجد هنا في هولندا وبعد ذلك
يعني ختمت الختم الثانيه والثالثه
والرابعه حتى السابعه يعني سبع ختمات
بالطريقه العتيقه يعني الطريقه المغربيه
كنا نستعمل اللوح حتى في هولندا نستعمل
اللوح
والمداد يعني كما كما هو الشان في المغرب
والحمد لله بعد ان انتهيت من حفظ القران
الكريم
سجلت في المعهد معهد القران الكريم التابع
للجامعه الاسلاميه في روتادام
فبعد سنه تقريبا جاءنا الشيخ يعني قارئ من
قراء تركيا يعني جامع للقراءات العشر
فاخذت عليه روايه ورش النافع بالسند
المتصل الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وبعد ذلك اخذت عليه اجازه في روايه حفص
العاصم كذلك بالسند المتصل الى رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم وبدات يعني ابحث عن
مشايخ اخرين لاخذ عليهم
الاسانيد لكن بعد طول الزمن وقف بالحاله
لان صرت اماما في احدى المساجد في المسجد
السلام انا لا اقلد يعني قارئا من القراء
واحاول ان اركز اكثر على الاحكام على
النطق الصحيح
من اكثر من النغمه او الاداء ان التعبير
فكنت اميل دائما الى الشيخ الحصري رحمه
الله تعالى لانه يعتبر عند القراء من اتقن
القراء في العصر الحديث فكنت اسمع للشيخ
الحصري كثيرا ومن الاصوات التي احبها
الشيخ الحذيفي حفظه الله تعالى
فيعني لكن التركيز دائما كان على الشيخ
الحصري
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله فاطر السماوات والارض جائع للم
لائكه رسلا
جاع
الملائكه رسلا
اجنحه
مثنى وثلاث ورباع
يزيد في الخلق ما يش
اء
ان الله على كل شيء قدير
[موسيقى]
ما يفتح الله للناس من رحمه
فلا ممسك لها
وما يمسك فلا مرسل له من بعده وهو العزيز
الحكيم
يا ايها الناس اذكروا نعمه الله عليكم
هل من خالق غير الله
يرزقكم
من الس
ماء ولا
لا اله الا هو
فانى توفيقون
[موسيقى]
وان يكذبوك فقد كذبت رسل
من قبلك
والى الله ترجع لم
ايها الناس ان وعد الله حق
فلا
تغرنكم الحياه الدنيا ولا يغرنكم
بالله
الغرور ان الشيطان لكم عدو
فاتخذوه عدوا
انما يدعو حزبه ليكونوا من اصحاب السعير
والله فعلا يعني انا اعتبر يعني من الجيل
الثاني لنحفظ القران الكريم نعم بدات
المشروع في المغرب لكنني حفظ القران
الكريم في هذا البلد
والله يعني انا ارى ان وضع الامام يختلف
في هذا البلد بالتحديد يختلف عن وضع
الايمان في الدول العربيه والاسلاميه لان
الامام لا يعني لا يؤم الناس في الصلوات
فقط ولا يقراوا يعني ما تيسر من القران في
المواسم والحفلات وانما الامام له دور اخر
وهو انه يرشد الناس
وياتيه الناس يعني
بمشاكلهم الخاصه مشاكل نفسيه مشاكل اسريه
فهو مرشد اسري ومرشد روحي
في بطحين طبيب حتى طبيب نفسي لان الامام
لان المسلمين ينظرون الى شخصيه الامام على
انه يستطيع ان يحل لهم جميع المشاكل
فنعم وضعيه الامام تختلف وهذا تحدي
بالمناسبه تحدي للامام لكي
يعني يستعمل العلم الذي وهبه الله اياه
والمعرفه التي التي عنده
ليكون يعني مفتاحا للخير في هذا البلد
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بقضايا الاسلام
والمسلمين هذا من جانب ومن جانب اخر ليبين
للناس الصوره الحقيقيه للاسلام
وخاصه نحن نعيش في زمن الصراعات اصطدام
الحضارات كما يسمى عند البعض
الفكر الغربي مشوش نوعا ما
خاصه حينما يتعلق الامر بقضايا الاسلام
والمسلمين فهذا الدور لابد ان يلعبه
الامام فيه في هذا البلد ومن حسن حظنا
ولله الحمد اننا تحت حتى باللغه الهولنديه
فهذا يتيح لنا الفرصه يعني كما قلت عشت
هنا في هذا البلد فتعلمت اللغه
وترى ان
الهولنديين او الغربيين من غير المسلمين
لاني اعتبروا نفسي مواطنا
في هذا البلد لكن اقصد بالغربيين يعني غير
المسلمين
تجد انهم يعني يريدون فعلا ان يتعرفوا عن
الاسلام وان يتعرفوا عن الصوره الحقيقيه
للاسلام ومن الامثله يعني الحديثه هو
اعتنا احد البرلمانيين الهولنديين اعتنقى
الاسلام قبل يعني قبل ايام وكان من
المعادين الاسلام لكنه حينما درس الاسلام
وتعرف على الاسلام يعني فتح الله عليه
واعتنق الاسلام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رغم اختلاف نمط الحياه الهولنديه عن موطنه
الامه المغرب استمر القارئ عز الدين قراءه
في التردد على المراكز الاسلاميه لتعلم
القران الكريم واتقان تلاوته بالطريقه
التقليديه المغربيه على يد عدد من القراء
المغاربه لينال الاجازه في القراءه بروايه
ورش عن نافع وايضا الاجازه بروايه حفص عن
عاصم فتسابقت المراكز الاسلاميه لكسبه
اماما وحافظا وخطيبا لعدد من المساجد في
مدينه روتردام ادعى لعده لقاءات مع غير
المسلمين مع المسيحيين مع اليهود حتى مع
يعني الملاحده ان صح التعبير فقد يتاثرون
بكلمتك قد يتاثرون بالدرس تلقيه بمحاضرات
تلقيها لكنك حينما تقرا القران تجد الجميع
استمع وينصت تجد ان الجميع ان الجميع يركز
وياتيك بعد يعني الق وبعد اللقاء يقول لك
بان هذا الصوت وهذه القراءه التي سمعها
اثرت فيه بجانب الجوانب
فهنا يستشعر الانسان عظمه القران ويستشعير
الانسان
مكانه القران حينما يتاثر به حتى غير
المسلمين وهم لا يفهمون ولا يفقهون شيئا
مما سمعوا لكن رغم ذلك
يتاثرون وهذا نلاحظ ايضا حتى عند شبابنا
جل الشباب المسلم هنا في هذا البلد لا
يتحدثون يعني باللغه العربيه لكنهم حينما
يقراون القران وحينما يحفظون القران عندنا
حفظ كثر لا يتحدثون العربيه لكنهم يتقنون
القران ويقراون قرانا القران القران
الكريم بكل اتقان فهذا من فضل الله وكرامه
ولله الحمد
والله يعني حينما نتحدث عن القراءه
بمفهومها يعني اللغوي
فتجد ان الجل يقراون بروايه ورش عن نافع
الحكم ان جل القراءنا فيها البلد من عندهم
خلفيات مغربيه ان صح التعبير ونجد ان
الاخوه الاتراك يقرون بروايه حفص لكن
حينما نتحدث عن عن الاداء فتجد ان جل
الناس يقراون
بنغمه مشرقيه صح التعبير يعني تجدهم في
الغالب يقلدون قراء الحرمين كالسديس مثلا
وغيره
هذا هو السائد لكن هنالك نماذج وهنالك
الحمد لله عندنا بعض الشباب يستطيع ان
يقلد ذلك جميع
القراء ويستطيع ان يقرا بجميع النغمات
الموجوده فلكل يعني
تخصص اشخاص يعني معينون يقراون بنغمه ما
او بروايه ما لكن السائد هي النغمه
المشرقيه وروايه ورش عن نافع
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
ان الذين قالوا ربنا الله ثم استقاموا
تتنزل عليهم الملائكه
ان الذين قالوا ربنا الله ثم
استقاموا تتنزل عليهم
الملائكه الا تخافوا
تتنزل عليهم
الملائكه الا تخافوا ولا تحزنوا وابشروا
وابشروا بالجنه التي
كنتم توعدون
نحن اولي
اؤكم في الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره
ولكم فيها ما تشتهي
انفسكم ولكم فيها ما تدعون
نزلا من غفور رحيم
[موسيقى]
ومن احسن قولا
دعا الى الله وعمل صالحا
وعمل صالحا
وقال
انني من المسلمين
ولا تستوي الحسنه ولا السيئه
ادفع بالتي هي احسن
فاذا الذي بينك وبينه عداوه
كانه ولي حميم
وما يلقاها
الا الذين صبروا
الا ذو حظ عظيم
صدق الله العظيم
والله يعني انا في عملي يعني امام انطلق
دائما
من القران الكريم الله عز وجل يقول في
كتابه الكريم واعتصموا بحبل الله جميعا
ولا تفرقوا فالايه واضحه الايه ستحدث عن
التفرقه حينما
نجعل من الاختلاف الموجود بين الناس هذا
سنه يعني سنه من سنن الله سبحانه وتعالى
في الكون ان نختلف لكن هنالك اصول ينبغي
ان نتمسك بها
فالتحجب وان تصنف نفسك مع مجموعه من
مجموعات
ويعني وتغلق المجال عن الاخر هذا يجعلك في
حيز ضيق جدا فلا تستطيع ابدا ان تنشر دين
الله سبحانه وتعالى بالطريقه الصحيحه التي
امرنا بها رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فالانسان لابد ان ينفتح عن الاخر وان يعني
ان يسعى جاهدا للوصول الى ما يسمى يعني في
القران الكريم بقضيه المؤاخاه ان اتاخر
فيما بيننا لان هذا هو الاساس الذي من
خلاله ينبغي ان ننطلق
يعني للتحدث مع الاخر وللحوار
مع الاخر فراى ان هذا الامر مهم
جدا وخاصه في بلد
جل
الناس فيه غير مسلمين فهذا النوع من انواع
المؤاخاه ينبغي ان نتمسك بها ايامه تمسك
ونسال الله عز وجل ان يوفقنا في ذلك ان
شاء الله والله اجواء رمضان يعني اجواء
متميزه صراحه في كل بلد لكن هي متميزه
اكثر في
بلد غير مسلم انا حينما يعني اخرج من
البيت وامشي الى المشي طبعا الى
المسجد تجد الناس ياتون افواجا يعني
عائلات اسر رجال نساء اطفال شيوخ كلهم
ياتون الى المساجد فتجد حتى المساجد
ممتلئه في بعض الاحيان عندنا في المسجد
كان العدد يصل الى 5000 شخص في رمضان
وانتم تعرفون بان العشاء في هذا البلد
وخاصه في يعني ايام الصيف يصف في بعض
الاحيان الى 12 ليلا لكنهم رغم ذلك ياتون
لصلاه التراويح
ويعني يتمسكون بهذه السنه ولو لم تكن فردا
لكنهم يتمسكون بها فتجد اقبال عجيب عن
صلاه التراويح والائمه يستغلون هذه الفرص
النادره صراحه
لنشري ثقافه القران الكريم
هنالك من ياتي دروس لكن جل المساجد ايضا
يخصصون هذا الموسم موسم رمضان لتعليم
الناس احكام التجويد
والقراءه الصحيحه اضافه الى الصلاه نفسها
الى التراويح
يعني التي نختم فيها كل رمضان نختم فيها
القران الكريم يعني من اوله الى اخره نصلي
التراويح والتهجد يعني كل يوم جزء سنختم
بهذا يعني الحمد لله نختم بهذا القران
الكريم في رمضان كاملا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]